yo it's power 98.3 man bootleg have my
dude in here you already know he's
headlining tonight yeah y'all remember
he uh headlined powerhouse last year for
us we got the homie the game in the
building did that man game what's up
brother how was the trip man y'all road
tripped it up here huh yeah man we came
up here about you know about 25 d as you
do that's you know typical game fashion
right there you know man arizona in the
backyard man so we had to come up here
you know what i'm saying blow all the
green out the window before we cross the
state lines and uh we made it man hey uh
why do you keep changing the instagram
name
first of all before you answer that i
appreciate you changing it from the
handsome ass you know yeah because you
know white people can't you know hey
what's game's instagram i can't you know
you end up like to do it on the eagles
you got all kinds of trouble man when
you got a problem yeah but yeah man once
i got to a million man instagram got
kind of boring so i'll just be doing all
kinds of tupac ain't dead is the new one
nah i switch it again man what what like
when just like 10 minutes ago
what is it now versace came right now
man versace king it might be bullet cavs
homeboy next yo do do that and just give
me some followers for like 10 minutes i
got you for like 10 minutes so you're
the versace king now
do you have to make that statement since
everyone's on this versace kick now you
know we've been on that man i mean but
even before um you know i was one of the
thought that i was the person that was
on it first i mean biggie was on it you
know what i'm saying
i mean beside you beside your massage
you know shout out to migos and all that
man just versace is a good it's a good
brand man all right so you had the the
jesus piece album which was an
incredible album amazing album man
incredible front to back what is next
for the game you gotta i know you're
always working on on music i know you
you know before before jesus speaks you
dropped a shitload of mixtapes yeah what
do we got coming up me and skee bout to
drop this okay mixtape um in like a week
or so um it's gonna be it's gonna be
crazy man got everybody on that thing
it's going to be real amazing i just
started um
back working with cool andre on a new
album oh nice y'all got some classics
together getting stuff from just blaze
the holiday dre i just let drake know
what it was you know working on the
sixth album he's like it's all good he's
going to china when he get back and so
on so you know i'm in there with stack
hard to start my new label the firm like
everybody killed it so it's a new label
the firm firm base yeah is that do you
have a deal with the label yet or no i
need no deal man i want no more deals
you do the independent thing no more
deals are you still technically signed
to interschool geffen or whatever the
hell it is yeah i'm trying to interscope
until i go have a meeting and see
whether i'm whether i'm moving on or
whether they want to read you know what
i'm saying redo it so we'll figure that
out have you have you hit the album like
quota or you still got to put out
another album no i don't know nothing i
i serviced all my albums that was due to
interscope and uh it's been a good run
so we'll go i'll go highlight berman and
uh jimmy i mean we'll see what i feel
like you're an artist that could you go
independent and you know you've got
people who
support your thing
i feel like drake kind of low-key messed
up signing i feel like drake could have
really changed the game yeah man he
could have man but and he signed but at
the same time man look what uh you know
young money did that's true in his
career you know what i'm saying it made
him a powerhouse and it sort of
propelled him from where he was you know
to where he is now man so you can't you
can't knock it you've worked with a lot
of artists man i feel like um despite
your your history with beefing with a
lot of artists i feel like game is like
kind of like everyone's homie like you
know what i'm saying
you're on the new tech nine album which
yeah man what's cool uh shout out to
tech man that's my homie man that's a
good dude one of the most independent
successful independent
you know technology got a lot a lot more
like a lot more money than everybody
than yes and almost everybody yeah doing
it man shout out to the homeboy tech man
who are you uh messing with those some
new artists of course outside of your
circle because i know you gonna shout
out your circle but who's the new artist
i'm messing with right now i'm just
chilling with um the two artists that i
got on the firm uh songstress by the
name of king gray i'm chilling with a
scheme every night in the studio scheme
isn't gee
still banging and slanging with uh
nipsey and kendrick and other day i was
in school boy i did my first song for
the new album schoolboy q uh which is
going to be a documentary for your new
album yeah so schoolboy was going to be
on the album definitely that's going to
be tight yeah um so we got cool andrea
on the new album school boy q on the
news
you know adam i mean of course the
actual suspects man i'm gonna go see the
swizzles and the timberlands and the
just blazes in a little while i'm gonna
give him some up-and-coming producers
you know a shot um you know to make it
you know we're gonna keep it moving
there was some talk that you were you
were thinking about joining cash money
is that still out there is that kind of
important thing about joining anybody
who can write that check man that's all
it is man i got you know three kids um
trying to have fun and we'll see uh you
know we see what they do man i just i
just saw the thing for the second the
second season of your show second season
of the show you know what i'm saying
another meal ticket to do a reality show
had to do it because my reality is crazy
um you know shout out to uh you know at
love tiffany man follower if you don't
already my kid's mom's wonderful and she
uh she dope man and my kids harlem on
king justice callie is the star this
whole
this whole season man so check it out
it's coming on august 5th that's the
night it's going to premiere it's going
to be dope and uh check out tr and tiny
that's from homeboy and that's coming on
two vh1 yeah i feel like t.i was the the
rapper who made it like okay for like
someone who hasn't fallen off to do a
reality show because usually if you see
the you know usually on the reality
shows there's always some cats who need
to do a reality show see i was that dude
who was like you know what i'm tip i'm a
king and we're gonna do this people
trying to get me to do reality show
since like my second album i never
wanted to do it then once tip did it i
was like you know he did it and he
stayed afloat right like yeah it's
possible to do it and then they came
with that you know they came to him so
you know yeah that's all that matters
you gotta get the bread hey i gotta talk
about some sports man i was mad last
year when the lakers hooked up on our
steve nash and i'm a sons fan sure it
didn't work out too well for y'all
though no what's going on with the
lakers are you are you on the clip clip
nation are you still rolling with the
lakers number one i'm la everything but
if i got to pick between the clippers
and the leggett's always going to be the
lakers that's the team i grew up
watching and i'm down with them kobe my
homeboy
along with a lot of clippers but i just
arrived for l.a man the black wall
street caught dwight howard in the
streets would it be all g
the old black wall street because you
know black wall street is diminished man
and uh we moved on that name is tainted
people get scared when they're here
thinking we're gonna shoot up something
that's why it's the firm now now it's
just fun man we don't we doing straight
business i gotta ask you that i feel
like there's always like
you always have new names for your
clique like y'all was the the goon squad
for a little bit yeah
and then
the rolly boys right rolly boys you got
we got into a little legal arm thing
with um rolex
even though he was buying everybody
rolexes yeah we did that you know what
i'm saying rogan's still popping shout
out to them but we got into a legal
thing and they all
they said that you know rolly boys rolex
records is too much of a likeness and
you know that like rolex the word was
created by the watch company if it was a
word that had been in use before them
you could have used it you could use it
so that's how ross got made back music
because maybe maybe that was the name
before that of course but so we backed
out of that without having to do any you
know losing any money and uh i spent the
last six months trying to figure out a
dope name and one day i listened to my
firm album and i call my lawyer my
account i'm like yo anybody copyright
firm
did you have to hit knives like yo nas
did you give him the heads up i didn't
even talk to nas about it but the firm
was an album it wasn't right you know
what i'm saying like a label or like you
know it was just that album so it's just
you know paying attention dre had a lot
of lot to do with the firm really had a
lot to do with that jury had a lot to do
with the game's career you know early on
and uh it's just all love man like i
said from the beginning of my career to
the end it's always gonna be a homage to
somebody and uh the firm is you know
that's me i want to ask you um i feel
like you you've always kept the same
cats around you since i've known you man
you've always had the same dudes rolling
with you yeah um no new friends no new
friends but i know that
in hip-hop
as a fan we always think that like oh
cause
someone did a song with somebody you
know their homies they kick it but you
know that's not always the case you know
sometimes it's business but who are some
dudes in the game that like
that you would consider your friend like
real like if if you fell off tomorrow i
ain't formal i'm saying
hypothetically no one was checking for
game no more you went bankrupt like mc
hammer
who's some dudes in the game that you
know will stand by you that you know are
just homies besides the music [__] um
fat joke fat joe yeah definitely buster
rhymes
uh spin i mean that's fabulous same
person um little chochie that's my dude
birdman mcmahon
i figured buster because i saw something
buster was talking about the same thing
like that's monday and then you guys you
guys have had some bangers together like
and then you know dj ski work for about
15 million now still 10 less still 10
million less than me but dj ski that's
my dude shout out to skee yeah skis
it's funny because like real [__] like
that's where ski took off was it was the
300 the 300 man yeah man
now he's got his own tv show and he
ain't [__] without your homeboys that's
what's up shout out to ski man shout out
to my dude the game uh the new album you
have a name for yet nah no telling thank
you are you gonna have some
controversial [__] like the last one
making everybody talking about your
album cover oh i don't know man you know
what game it's always gonna be
controversial to somebody okay and uh
the firm um
you've you've had like you said black
wall street was tainted you had so many
artists come through the black wall
street umbrella clyde carson you know
juice menace
um is there a reason why nobody ever
came out from black wall street
officially like in stores you know what
i'm saying uh and like i said politics
yeah it wasn't politics man it was we it
wasn't about business with us man we was
you know running around with six seven
guns everywhere we go and getting the
fights and just you know killing the
brand man um you know internally and so
um finally you know a little bit more
wise a little over demanding so now i
got a brand that i can build fresh and
hand-picked artists from scratch and
producers and really pick people that
are amazing and you know get this label
off the ground do you find yourself that
you've gotten older you of course your
kids are getting older do you put
yourself in um
better situations now because i know you
know
you run la you know you go every you
want but i know sometimes
you put yourself in a certain situation
as a hip-hop artist you go to certain
spots you know where you know there
might be some trouble brewing do you try
to avoid those situations now uh nine
times out of ten man i just go where i
want and do what i want and i'm pretty
much uh respected um you know globally
well you know just internationally at
home man wherever i go i'm good in the
hood um sometimes you run into you know
somebody that's a problem or they want a
problem and it's got to be addressed um
five times out of ten i'm gonna turn my
cheek and go the other way and the other
five like spin on how i feel that day
you'll get rolled on like 40 i'm gonna
have to you know maybe man but i i don't
want none of that i don't want to be
from nobody ain't trying to fight trying
to get nobody hurt or nothing like that
just want to make my music take care of
my family go around the world my friends
man just you know come back to arizona
every now and then yeah that's my place
we got love for you out here you know so
that's what's up man well hey i
appreciate you tonight you already know
his headline and it's going down the
game recognize game tour celebrity
theater you're gonna brush out the
bottle of goose chug tonight you know
what it might just be bel air man get
that black you know i'm a black bottle
boy so i had to bring out the ballet